hi i'm christopher hein and today we're
going to be talking about uh conrad
nawaza and so this is one of a
three-part series on the conrenawaza for
udeose the first part of this was the
takedown for the udeose and this part is
going to be on i can't take them down so
i'm
i'm trying all my tricks to get them
down and they won't go down what do i do
after that and so this looks at the the
controls that happen immediately after
and also the escapes a little bit what
happened immediately after
i'm going to call josh over here we're
going to go to work josh
okay so now we're going to talk about
the udeo say position and i cannot
possibly get the takedown so all the
conran for the takedown are the dominant
step through once you know he's touching
on three points to pull him back and
forth between those points so wherever
he's adjusting his hand to adapt to that
and then
i can also in addition to that use the
ikkyo the rokyo going straight into the
shoulder and i can use the wrist in lots
of ways to help get him down now let's
say we have a guy that i absolutely
can't take down and i need to deal with
this guy right so um let me give you an
example what i mean
so i have a guy here and i just can't
get him down i i really can't just do
this right and so our aikido context
says yeah get out of there right so if i
can't get this guy quickly to go down
i've got to worry about other people but
for whatever reason in this situation i
can't just do that now if i wanted to
make the cleanest escape possible i'm
going to
escape to the back right so what i want
to do is this this is my action here to
get away from there and it's the safest
position so that's the eating me
position so transitioning any kind of
udeo say into edemi is my next position
variation right so this is the next
position i want to get into right
and that leads to a lot of stuff um we
can talk about how the urowaza variation
and lots of things go into there but
we're going to talk right from this
position right now okay now
one thing i said from here is you can go
into rokyo this rokyo option is
relatively weak because i'm just doing
it with my hands we can go into a formal
rokio pin so if i really just have to
get this guy down maybe a situation
where i know it's one on one or i have
numbers on my side and i know i just
need to take him down i can shoot
through here and drop all of my body
weight on this elbow and this puts a ton
of weight onto this elbow and makes it
really hard for him to do anything i've
used this many times trying to deal with
angry aggressive people in non-organized
situations right so so i'm here like
this and then i can really drive in and
i can get my whole body weight in there
which is really really nice to do that
but it's a little beyond what we're
going to talk about in this we're going
to talk about situations that fix this
okay now understand i'm trying to roll
that echo but if he dislikes me trying
to roll the echo he's going to push his
elbow back as he's standing up right so
what he's looking for is this stand up
if i can tell he's doing that one thing
i can do is prep his hand in advance
right now as he stands up with that prep
he's putting himself uh see he doesn't
want to stand up now because he's
putting himself into nico if i feel that
he's too strong so if my grip's not
strong enough and he stands up and he
can tear his hand out of there then what
i do is i put this on my body and i can
put all my body weight into this now as
he tries to stand up no go right so even
a really small person can usually get
some benefit out of this with the wrist
now there's lots of things about the
nico and we get to the chondru and
fornica we'll talk about all the little
adaptations but understand that if i
can't get this guy down i can adjust my
grip here and then let him come up
essentially and he won't want to because
of this nico now the moment that he hits
the nikkyo and rolls forward to get away
from the nikki i can then drive down we
see this in the nico multiform right so
we see the same basic idea in the nicole
multiform
likewise once i've got here i can put a
lot of force into that to try and get
him to go where i want now notice once i
apply the nico what josh inherently
wants to do this turn his back which
makes it easier for me to make my eating
me for my escape right so again if it's
like i just got to get out of there at
this point i realized he's got friends
or whatever and i want to get out of
there i can turn that knee through he
turns his back a little bit and that
gives me a second to get out
okay now let's say this guy can stand up
all the way so he stands up boom all the
way my nico's not strong enough to hold
him here and i didn't get to place it
against my body to lock myself down so i
got into a bad position so as he comes
up i can transition into sankyo right
now look this isn't i'm not trying to
hold this all day this is not my super
control position if i'm a lot bigger
than him that might work out but if he's
bigger than me this is going to be a
momentary thing so i can get out of
there right so and actually my exit
should be made this way is what i should
be looking for um but that's my idea
right is so from here i'm just looking
to make my escape now if i'm a lot
bigger than him i can control and go
into all the sankia stuff but from this
udeo say position if this guy goes to
get up i naturally get sankyo here so it
goes right into sankhya so if you're
having an uke who's loving to resist
resist resist let him stand up and he'll
pop right into that okay now another
conrad adaptation for this is we find in
psychosense form which is from this
control position get further control
over the elbow so see i've gone elbow to
elbow so he can't get up while that's
happening sneak under here and grab his
hand and now the second he tries to
raise he's getting right into that
sankyo so he's turning that sankyo
immediately which makes it really really
strong
another thing that can be done with this
is rokyo so for sorry yonkyo yonkyo from
him getting up i set up a yonkyo so now
if he wants to get up and i relieve the
pressure of this he gets up just like
that and he wants to drop this arm
because that's more comfortable so if i
go from here to here the second he
starts to raise up i hit that yonkyo
spot so all i'm doing is sliding from
here to here and we see this again
inside the sensei's form where the ikkyo
is not working out for us so when he
tries to get up we pop down here and he
goes right into that yonkyo spot and
we're sliding right into yonkyo when we
get to the conren for yonkyo we'll talk
about all the different yonkyo positions
from there but all these ideas are based
on him standing up right so he wants to
stand up and then of course if he gets
all the way up we have all the conrads
that we had from ikkyo that we talked
about before so you can revisit that
section if he actually gets up and i
didn't manage to maintain the control so
again from this position if we're trying
to make our takedown that was the last
video this video is him trying to get up
i can set up the nico so as he gets up
he runs right into nikki if i need to be
stronger to do that i put it against my
body i turn in and we get the nikki i
can also if he comes up right straight
from here i can turn on the sankyo and i
can prep my sankyo by sliding in coming
around and then as he gets up bang
there's my sankyo again i can also use
the moment of him trying to rise to set
up the yonkyo and as he comes in he'll
hit my yonko immediately and that again
gives me a moment to escape
so what we're looking at and all these
conor in here is adaptations for when
he's resisting me getting up everything
in conron's about not you not getting
your way and what are you going to adapt
to when you don't get your way so in
aikido forums we really get rigidly
stuck into the idea that i'm always
going to successfully pull off this form
but there are lots of moments that
aikido trains you for if you don't do
that and so you just gotta understand
how to pull those out of the form so
this is iffy standing up from the udeose
position and how to deal with that i'm
christopher hines joshua teehee my
solana mcdaniels behind the camera
thanks for watching
[Music]
you